the Trump versus the santis elements of
the primary are getting ugly even though
Ron DeSantis still hasn't even announced
that he is running a pro-desantis pack
has released an ad which ran for the
first time on Fox News yesterday
directly attacking Donald Trump now
remember
Trump has spent a bunch of time
attacking DeSantis as well and you could
say that's just the silly or pathetic
Trump's going after a guy who hasn't
even said that he's actually running and
I'm with you but here is a pro DeSantis
pack going after Trump already and
DeSantis hasn't announced that he's
running for president this is
fascinating take a look Donald Trump is
being attacked by a Democrat prosecutor
in New York so why is he spending
Millions attacking the Republican
governor of Florida Trump stealing pages
from the Biden Pelosi Playbook repeating
lies about social security here's the
truth from Governor Ron DeSantis no
we're not going to mess with Social
Security as Republicans what did Trump
say entitlements ever be on your plane
at some point they will be we will take
a look at them should fight Democrats
not lie about Governor DeSantis what
happened to Donald Trump Never Back Down
Inc is responsible for the contents yeah
okay so um I have to tell you the the ad
itself is pretty lame from a factual
standpoint like the big thing that
they're insisting on talking about is
cuts to Social Security and the way that
it's going is is as follows
all of these Republicans likely at some
point played coy
with whether reforming by which they
might mean cutting Social Security and
Medicare is on the table the ad
accurately points out that Trump at one
point said well I think that's something
that we're going to look at
Trump has alleged that DeSantis tried to
cut it DeSantis voted in favor
of a plan to reform which might have
included raising the Social Security age
of retirement age but it was non-binding
it's sort of like the factual story is
very weak they're all exaggerating about
each other's desire to cut Social
Security although I have no doubt at all
that if it was politically advantageous
they would do it what's important about
this is the fact that the attacks
themselves are a major part of what's
going on right now the uglier the
primary
the worse it is for republicans and for
whoever is the eventual nominee you will
see some people argue that a spirited
primary is a good thing for republicans
and often they will argue when you have
a tough primary it's a test of the
candidate's strength and resilience and
their ability to appeal to different
segments of the Republican electorate
and the winner is going to come out
battle tested okay that's the argument
that they make I've not seen evidence of
that what I have seen evidence of is
that the type of Republican party that
exists today is a resentful
grudge-holding Republican party with a
particularly uninformed electorate who
often only cares about one candidate
they don't really care about the
Republican party and so what we've seen
is that the more divisive the primary it
can lead to these irreparable fractures
and factions within the Republican Party
supporters of different candidates who
become disillusioned disillusioned when
their candidate loses and they may not
even end up voting in the general
election so I think in 2023-2024
this ugly Republican primary is
potentially going to turn Republican
voters off altogether through the
negativity and the mud slinging and the
fractured nature of the party if these
Republicans truly believe that an ugly
primary is good for them well it looks
like they're going to get one and we'll
be able to figure out over the next 18
months or so is this actually a good
thing for the eventual Republican
nominee I believe the answer is no if
you think this is good for the
Republican Party an ugly primary let me
know and we'll have the ad on our
YouTube channel as well as on Instagram
as well as on the Spanish YouTube
channel
davidpackman.com Spanish one of our
sponsors is electric e-bikes I've been
watching e-bike reviews on YouTube for a
while because I've been thinking of
getting one and I continually come
across electric as the brand to go with
if your budget is between 800 and 1300
and I have to agree from experience I've
had my electric e-bike for a little
while now now I've almost ditched my car
and regularly bike at this point for
errands and things around my
neighborhood it's awesome cardio because
I'm still pedaling I get there faster I
can see more I'm reducing my carbon
footprint the e-bike came to my doorstep
fully assembled it has a bright LCD
screen seven speed gearing five levels
of pedal assist a powerful battery that
you can take inside to charge it's also
fully foldable I can put it in the back
of my car electric has models for every
lifestyle and you can Finance for as
little as 73 bucks a month go to
electricebikes.com to learn more explore
all of the incredible e-bike models they
offer the link is down below